I take everything
you like. All right, good
morning everyone.
Everyone having a good time at Reinvent.
This is actually my first reinvent.
I spent most of my career on the Microsoft
side of technology, so, uh, this has
been interesting to kind of compare
some of the big Microsoft conferences with,
uh, With AWS and Amazon,
so I'm excited to be here.
Uh, my name is Colin Dembovsky. I'm the
director of field services for GitHub co-pilots.
Uh, so I spend my entire, uh,
days
meeting with products and with
our field services teams, and
with customers, and with partners,
and discuss all of the things that
uh we're building and we're, uh,
helping customers with in this age
of AI.
Uh, so I'll go through a little bit of my journey. I
will say that I'm from South Africa and I wanna
clear up. Well, I'm from South Africa originally. I'm based
outside of Houston now.
But I wanna clear up that I don't have the accent.
All you all have the accent. All right. So I
just wanna make sure that we've clear, we clear that up.
Uh, but I've been with GitHub for about 4 years, uh,
just over 4 years.
Uh, I was a solution engineer for most of that time
before taking on this role.
Uh, and as you can imagine, over the last 4 years, most
of our discussions have been very heavily.
Weighted towards co-pilot, we actually do
have a whole platform in GitHub. We've
got advanced security, which you'll see some of
today. We've got the
biggest CICD platform in the world
in the world with GitHub Action. So we actually do have
a whole platform,
but of course Co-Pilott is dominating that
and dominating the minds of our customers.
So what I'm going to do today is I want to
just take a kind of a journey. Through a
little bit of computer science history. This is not
meant to be comprehensive, but
I think it's useful to just frame where we are
in the industry.
I'll give you some insights into what I'm seeing
as trends in the industry, what I'm seeing with some
of my customers,
and show you what we're planning for,
what we're building towards in the future.
So that will help frame what we're doing with
GitHub co-pilot,
and then we'll end off with a couple of demos
and I'll take some questions. So
that's what we'll do this morning.
So I wanna start with this slide here and
uh maybe by show of hands,
if you don't mind dating yourself, does
anyone know what this is?
Yeah, OK, so I see a few hands. Thank you
for your service. Um, but these are punch
cards.
And, uh, if you think about 40, 50
years ago, so not that long ago,
this is how developers,
or programmers programmed
computers.
And uh, the punch card on the left
there, you can kind of see there's holes punched out of it.
And uh those are zeros, and where there's
not a hole, it's a 1. So you were literally
programming in binary by punching holes
into a card.
And then you would put these cards in order, and
so on the right-hand side you can see a box, so that
is a program because it's a series of
cards, and you would feed those cards
into the computer to program that computer.
So I like to pause at this stage
and ask a rhetorical
question that you can think about a little bit.
And the question is, uh, how long
do you think it took
developers who use this method
to program computers to become
productive developers?
Or maybe another way of phrasing it was,
how long do you think it took to go
from idea to deployment when this was
how you programmed computers?
Alright, so we're probably talking months,
you know, assuming you didn't drop your stack of
cards
and forget which order they were in.
Alright, but uh you can see how this was
great for the beginning of computers, but
uh it would have taken a very long time
to get any idea into production.
So we had some very smart people in the
industry and they decided, well, you know, these punch card
things are not that great. What if we
took a typewriter essentially and put it in front
of the computer.
And then at least we didn't need punch cards. We could actually
use the keys on the typewriter
to type in, and we could use the printer
as a screen, right? You don't see any monitors
there. The printer that printed the paper
was the monitor that you would use to see
what the computer was doing and to see the outputs.
And uh these two gentlemen here are
Ken Thompson and Dennis Ritchie. Anyone know what these
folks are famous for?
C? Oh well,
what did, what did Ken Thompson invent before
C? B, yes, right.
And Dennis Ritchie
and Ken Thompson worked on Unix, right?
So, uh, this was slightly better. Again,
I'll, I'll pause and ask a question. When you had a
typewriter and a dot matrix printer, remember
the sound of those dot matrix printers, right?
Uh, when that was how you interfaced with
computers, how long did it take you to go from
idea to production? How long did it take you to
become a productive developer? It's
probably still in months or weeks,
right? So
now fast forward a little bit
to the early 1990s,
uh, when I was in high school. And this was
the first programming language that I ever
learned. Uh, this was Turbo-Pascal
7. Any Turbo-Pascal fans out
there? Yeah, yeah, yeah. Any,
anyone a fan of of C?
Or, uh, TypeScripts.
Well, they're all written by Anders
Hallsbrand, who's invented Turbo Pascal,
right? So,
um, but
for you younguns in the audience here,
when you wanted to
program back in the 90s, you literally
bought a compiler. So that is Turbo
Pascal, and it came on a couple of
disks that you would have to feed into the computer to
load the compiler on.
And then when you wanted to figure out how do I do
a function call, how do I do a for loop,
how do I pass arguments, you had to
open up those things on the left-hand side there, they're
called books. They have pages, and you have to like
turn them, right? And that's how you would learn
programming, is you would open up these books and you would learn
the programming concepts. Now,
up until this stage, uh, you've got monitors
and you've got com uh, you know,
computers with 640K of memory,
and a 20 megabyte hard drive, and a
16.
Uh, color grayscale or 1616
grayscale monochrome monitor, right?
So we're like, these were still pretty advanced
times uh during the 90s.
But again, you're still talking weeks or months
to go from idea to deployment.
Anyway, then I studied computer science
at a small university college in uh.
In South Africa, in a town called Grahamstown,
called Rhodes University. It was a great time. I
did 6 years there, doing a master's degree
in Computer Science. I had, had an absolute blast.
And then I got into the real world where I had to
be a programmer, and I had to actually put some
of that learning into use.
And uh, the first company I ever joined, they were
Linux C++, and we wrote back-end systems
for internet service providers, right? So if you
think back to the early 2000s, when you signed
up for an internet,
Uh, for internet services, you've got things like
inboxes and um
anti-virus, and you've got all these other services
that came, and we, we wrote the systems
that these internet service providers would use
to provision services to their customers. It was
all Linux and C++ and Corba, if
anyone remembers Corba.
Uh, but I, I put this, I put this up
here because uh.
There were no such things as IDEs.
You were essentially
typing code into a text file, and
this actually has syntax highlighting, cause I generated
in VS code, and we're the editors I had
back then, in the early 2000s, didn't even
have syntax highlighting, but you can see all the prints
all over the place. Anyone,
anyone ever do printF debugging?
Right, yeah, you had to put entering method,
the value of iterator is exiting
method, and you put little timers to see
which methods were going fast or slow, or
then you would run the application and all these logs
would scroll down the console, and then you would scratch
through all of those logs to figure out what was going on in
your program, right? So
we're definitely getting higher level um
programming here,
but again, it still takes a long time
to do anything productive, and there's a long
time from idea to production.
My second job
was at a company, it was a financial
services company.
We had about 25 developers
when I joined.
Uh, and they brought me on as a senior
developer, and they gave me Visual
Studio. Anyone a Visual Studio user
here?
OK, a couple of hands, thank you for admitting that.
Um, but Visual Studio was a fantastic
editor. It still is a great editor. I use VS code
now because it's a little bit more lightweight, but Visual
Studio is a great editor, but,
Being able to set a breakpoint, right, and
actually uh
stop the application while it was running. You
don't see any print Fs anywhere there,
but I was able to stop the program, see what the variables
were, and that made me a much
faster developer because I didn't
have to litter my program with print
des all over the place.
And uh and so now we're talking probably weeks,
right? Our, our deploy cycles were about in the,
in, measured in about weeks.
All right. And then uh I
put this XKCD cartoon up here,
because uh I got into DevOps consulting,
right, when I, that company I joined, they were
using Zip files for source control.
And I was like, well, I might not know much about the uh
Microsoft stack, but there's gotta be a better way of
doing source control. And so I opened
up a web crawler, and this was like pre-Gogle,
and, uh, and found this tool called
Team Foundation Server 2005
Beta 2, which is a precursor to
Azure DevOps, as it's known today.
Uh, and I got that installed and got our team onto
source control, and then eventually automated
builds, and eventually unit testing and work
item tracking and all of the
software development things that we take for granted
today. Sort of in the early 2000s,
these were quite, quite novel concepts, right?
And so I remember Friday afternoons, we would
get together, we had a couple of scripts, but you would
still have to run them. So we called it auto-manual,
right, cause we were running scripts manually.
And we would have someone who was grilling meat,
and if your commit broke the build, you didn't
get to eat. So, that was our rule, all right.
Uh, so I put that up there because I love this XKCD
cartoon, because back in those days, you know, to
do a compile actually took a lot of
time and energy, and it took you away from
doing development work.
Uh, but at least it made you slightly faster
than if you had to
right click and publish, right? One of my friends used
to say, friends, don't let friends right click
publish out of Visual Studio. So we
were getting into automated builds, and
uh this was around the time that Agile
was really taking off in the industry.
Um, my blog is called Collins ALM Corner,
because, uh,
back then we spoke about application life cycle
management. So this was before
the term DevOps was coined, right?
So I kind of wish my blog was now Collins DevOps
Corner or something, but Collins ALM Corner is
nostalgic, so
I'll just keep it there. But,
uh, so I spent the next decade of my career
helping teams move from Waterfall
into agile, so that they could deploy
quicker, that they could go from
idea
to production faster.
This blog post is actually from
the GitHub blog.
It's dated 2008.
And uh one of the early founders of GitHub
put this little blog post up
and uh said, oh yeah, there's
pull requests now. So if you did not know
who created the pull request, or
invented the pull request, it was actually GitHub. So
in 2008,
we invented the pull request, and of course,
most of us nowadays, the pull request is
really the center of our entire development workflow.
Uh, but even back in those days, in 2008,
GitHub was on the forefront of innovation
for software delivery.
Um, this was also around the time when open
source really started taking off and taking
the industry
by storm.
So again, I'm gonna do a little bit of a fast forward
to 2021.
Uh, so I put this blog post up, uh,
it's dated February 23rd, 2022,
uh, when we put out a blog post saying
that we're introducing the world to this technical
preview of this little product called GitHub
Co-Pilot. Anyone, anyone using Co-Pilott
today? All right, I see a lot of hands,
which is great.
All right, so I, I put this up here because,
uh, most people back in February
of 2022 did not know what an
LLM was.
They had no idea what transformers were, they had
no idea what generative AI was.
Uh, but we were already experimenting with this.
In fact, I joined, uh, GitHub in
September of 2021,
and remember using GitHub co-pilot in
December of 2021,
uh, during the advent of code, which I'll talk
about in a couple of seconds, but, uh,
It was only really nine months after this
blog post in November
of 22 that Chat GPT blew
up and and became kind of a household
name when OpenAI released it
to the public, and suddenly everyone knew what models
and LLMs and generative AI
was. But we're, we're certainly about a year
ahead of that, right? And so I put this up here,
again, just to show that um we,
this came out of a group inside of GitHub
called GitHub Next. It's also sort of our R&D division.
That are uh always doing pretty radical
things, but they, they, they're the, the
brains behind GitHub co-pilot,
and uh I wanted to show that we're
leading in those innovations.
Now, anyone here ever done the advent of
code?
Alright, a couple of hands. Alright, this is really
fun. Uh, I actually I haven't even looked at this year's
competition yet, but, uh, there's a
guy that creates these puzzles, and there's 2 puzzles
a day from the 1st to the 25th of December.
And you can solve them however you want with
whatever programming language you want, and they get progressively
more difficult.
Uh, so last year I made it up to day 19
before, uh,
before I gave up. Uh, but that's how I
learned how to use, uh, GetUp Co-Pilott was
doing advent of Code in December of 2021.
Highly recommend you check it out if you're, uh,
on leave and bored.
Uh, you may wanna check out Advent of Code. It's a really
fun, uh, little exercises that you
can do. But I used a TypeScript repo,
and I was like, hey, what can co-pilot do to help
me solve these problems and.
This was back in the stone ages
of GitHub co-pilot, or it
feels like the Stone Ages. It was actually sort of 3 and a
bit years ago,
uh, where we had code completion.
All right, and that was how we started with GitHub Co-Pilott,
was
where a human was writing in a
code file, right, in a TypeScript file
or a C file or a Java file, or whatever
file you were in.
And uh you wrote a comment or
you opened up a bracket to start a function.
And the co-pilot would inject
a suggestion for you,
and uh I remember the first time I ever
got a completion, it was mind-blowing.
I was like, how did it know that that was
what I was going to type, right, and so there was this magical
feeling about
the power of
co-pilot and code completions.
So I wanted to come back to the XKCD
cartoon, where developers are slacking
off because there's a compiler, and I wanna give an
updated version of the XKCD
cartoon, right.
And this is probably something that you've heard a lot of
at this conference, and.
If you look at Google or Microsoft,
or OpenAI or any of
these top companies,
everyone's talking about agents, agents, agents.
A year ago it was models, models, models. Now
models are more more or less a commodity.
Everyone's talking agent, agent, agent, and
now we have
this world where the agent is working
on your behalf. And what is the
point of this?
It's to make you a faster, more
productive developer.
It's to shorten that time from
idea to deployment. That is
the goal,
that should be the goal of what the agents
are doing.
So uh we, we think about these waves,
I'll talk a little bit more about uh
these waves, but wave one was
that pair programmer paradigm with
code completion,
where a human is,
In the forefront in a
text file and you're having code completions,
and then we're moving into wave
2, a little bit into flavors
of wave 3,
where the wave wave 2 is
where the agents have become a lot more
capable
and they're able to work more autonomously.
And that opens up new opportunities where
they can work asynchronously. You can give them
whole tasks now and get them to complete
those tasks
on your behalf asynchronously,
and that's giving birth to what we're referring
to as the agentic SDLC.
Alright, and so how do we think about how agents
are changing the software delivery life cycle?
How are they actually making us more
productive, or are they actually making
us more productive? It's something we spend a lot
of our time and effort thinking about.
And we're moving towards wave 3, which is
these hybrid teams, where you'll have teams
of developers working with fleets of
agents
to deploy and again get from
idea to deploy as quickly as
possible.
All right, so I wanted to show some data. Uh,
this
is from our own internal analysis
of GitHub co-pilot across all of
our customers.
And, uh, those bars there are showing
a couple of things. So they're, on the left-hand side
is uh non-copilot,
right? And so you, we've divided up each of
those bars
into,
uh, the median, the high, and the top
10% of developers, right? And so you can kind of
see on the left-hand side.
Um, there's some velocity there, and
of course the high-performing developers
have a larger velocity, a larger throughput
than other developers.
And then you add CCA, which is co-pilot
coding agent, which is our asynchronous agent,
where you can give it a task and it will go away
and complete that task autonomously.
Uh, you can see that the throughput increases.
And if we then enable
uh CCR,
uh, we'll co-pilot with CCAs
on the right-hand side, right? So the, the middle one is just
using co-pilot and your editor.
The one on the right is using coding agent, and
you can see when developers start to use co-pilot
and the asynchronous coding agent,
their throughput and their productivity
starts to skyrocket.
Uh, the contribution graph on the right-hand
side or the contribution numbers on the right-hand side
are from the repo GitHub GitHub, which
is the main mono repo for the GitHub
platform. And uh you can see
the number 2 there is 397
contributions.
Alright, that is in a one-month period. So
our highest human contributed about
400 contributions to GitHub, GitHub.
But co-pilot coding agent,
Did 5x of that.
All right, so 1500 contributions.
And coming in a strong third place is the
co-pilot code review agent. So,
internally, we're using coding agent
and code review agent very heavily to
augment our teams and
to improve our velocity.
Um, so we're dog fooding that. We consider ourselves
to be customer zero for co-pilot
and the rest of our platform. We use GitHub to build
GitHub. Uh, we use GitHub very
heavily internally,
um, but we see,
Uh, from our stats and from looking at,
uh, the,
the data science behind the pull
requests, we see 20% faster
mergers with co-pilot code review, right? So
if your lead time,
when you open a pull request to when you close a
pull request is 5 days without code
review, we're seeing that when you enable
code review agent, you're gonna shrink that from
5 days to 4 days, right, which is a 20%
improvement. Right, Imagine if you're taking
20 or 25 days to close your
PRs. If you can get a 20% improvement,
you're getting down to 10 or 15 days, right, and that's
just code review agent, nevermind coding agent
or co-pilot.
Uh, so we're seeing, uh, the, the proof is
in the pudding,
and uh we're seeing that across the board. Of
course you can get more if you're more intentional
about it. So hopefully I can give you some ideas today
about how to be more intentional,
so that you can really maximize the gains
and the
productivity improvements you'll get from our platform.
Right, but there's a challenge,
because uh if co-pilot is
helping you create more code faster,
that means you have more to plan,
you have more to review,
you have more to test and scan, you have
more to operate,
and you have more to integrate, especially if you've got disparate
tools across your SDLC.
Alright, and uh, the integration, as
one of my computer science professors used to
say, Interchangeable parts don't,
right, I have a lot of uh customers
throughout my years as a DevOps consultant that
had, uh, there were, some of them, there was a swing
where everyone wanted one system that did
everything, and then there was a swing to,
well, we want the best in breed tools, and we'll just integrate
them, right, and that. Never seemed to work
out because you ended up spending a lot of time on
the integration instead of solving your
business problems and your customers'
problems. So we don't want you to do that.
So our vision is to be the backbone of your
SDLC.
We always build with uh integration
and uh
uh APIs for
other tools when you need them,
uh, but we wanna be that backbone
for your entire SDLC, not just
in the code generation space. Alright, so
co-pilot started.
To help code generation, but we're thinking
very deeply about how can we bring genetic
capabilities to planning, to reviewing,
to testing and securing and to operating.
And that's what I want to go over in this
next section.
So, again, I'll bring up these waves.
Um, these 4 waves are actually defined
by Microsoft, and we've kind of adopted some
of their language there.
Uh, so again, that wave 1 was assistance,
where you can think of, I'm in a code
file and I'm getting assistance from code completion.
Uh, then there's augmentation where I'm
able to give,
uh, I'm able to get the agent to edit
multiple files at the same time.
Uh, so there's augmentation.
And then there's orchestration, which is kind of where we are
now with autonomous agents.
And, uh, how can we, how can we
get these agents to run autonomously
and asynchronously and in a multi-threaded
fashion.
And then wave 4 would be
full autonomy, right, where we actually trust these
agents to go.
Uh, completely from end to end where agents are
talking to agents, and, uh,
that's where we're headed, that's where we see the
industry going. So we're somewhere in the wave
2 to wave 3, we've got pieces of wave
4.
So what I wanna do for the next couple of slides is show you
just a conceptual vision of
what it could look like when you're in wave 4.
And again, we have a lot of the pieces today,
but I wanted to give you sort of an aspirational vision
of what we're trying to build for
you. Alright, so let's imagine that
you have a brainstorming agent and you're
gonna brainstorm some feature or some bug fix.
You're gonna create a plan with a work breakdown,
and all of this is being done with the agent's help.
Then you're gonna pass all of those tasks to coding agents,
which are going to actually do the coding, so they're going to take
all of those
tasks from your plan and code them up,
and then they'll, Pass the coding changes to
security and quality agents that are going to check
that there are no vulnerabilities, that there are no vulnerable
dependencies,
that the quality is good.
And then you're gonna have a human review,
right, cause we still believe very strongly in human in
the loop. So, the human will review.
And then once you're deployed, we envision
SRE agents, site reliability
engineer agents, right? Microsoft has an
SRE agent on the Azure platform.
We saw this week in the keynotes
that Amazon released the DevOps
agent, which is the same idea. How can we use
the agents to monitor production
environments and then feed that back into
the life cycle. So you can imagine that happening
across one work stream, across one sprint team,
and then you can have that in parallel
across multiple.
Uh, work streams within that team.
While the team is going, the SRE agent
or whatever flavor it is, finds an
issue in production,
grabs the context from that issue,
logs it back as an issue to assign
decoding agent, which then has all the context
it needs to go and fix that issue,
goes and goes back through the scanning
and securing,
and there's human review and you deploy
out. And then you can imagine this
going across multiple teams and multiple
business units
across your engineering teams.
So that's kind of the high level vision
of what we're trying to create and what we're trying
to get to.
And so we want to bring those agentic capabilities
not just to code generation to make developers
faster, but how can we help you plan faster?
How can we help you secure and build trust
in what the agents are producing
faster? How can we get you faster in
the meantime to remediate, and all of those
good DevOps
practices?
How can we make you faster with the power of
these agents? So that's what we're ultimately building.
Let's see here. Anyone, uh, go or
watch Universe 2025?
Does anyone know what universe is? OK, there's
a couple of hands. Alright, so Universe is our
equivalent of reinvent, um, it's our annual
conference.
It happens, uh, late October every
year in San Fran. So we had,
uh, Universe 2025, about, oh what was
it, 4 weeks ago-ish, Somewhere around there. And,
uh, if I had to summarize all of the ships and
announcements we made,
it would be the simple sentence, the rise
of agents. And that's really summarizing
what we.
have been working on for the last 6 to 8
months and all of the announcements that we made. So
I want to go through some of those.
Again, I'm trying to paint a picture here, so
that you understand what we're doing, because we're shipping
fast, we're shipping a lot, and so we
often hear
that customers get,
Overwhelmed with all of the changes that we're
throwing at them, and I'm trying to give you
a framework here to how you can think about what
we're doing and building. So,
again I've spoken about this a little bit.
That we're accelerating coding, which is kind of in the middle
of your
SDLC, your software delivery life cycle,
is, can I produce faster
code, or can I produce code faster? Can
I get the agents or the uh
coding assistant
to take mundane tasks off my hands
so that I can be more creative,
do more high value work. And so I
would say we've been doing a really good job of that.
But what we wanted to do is also look at how can we
clarify intent, how can we shift left into
more planning work? How can we get agents
to help with that,
uh, and so we released a planning agent,
which I'll demo.
Um, we've also got the brainstorming agent
coming soon.
Um, so we're thinking about how we can shift those agentic
capabilities into that plan phase,
even before you start coding, right?
And anyone who's used any of these
coding agents, you'll know that when you say build me
an app,
You get very mediocre results,
but when you say, I need an app that does,
and you specify what you want the app to do and
what you want the stack to look like, and how you want it to
work, and how you develop and what your standards are,
you get much better results. So it's all about clarifying
the intent early on so that you get
better results.
And then if we look to the right, it doesn't help if we
help you
create code and code changes faster,
if you have to spend more
time securing and validating,
And checking quality and validating
the output of those agents and
of those agent workflows.
So what are we doing to help build
trust so that you know once it's got through
your gates
and your quality bars that you are
confident you can deploy. So how, how are we
doing that? And that's really what we've been thinking about.
One more concept I wanna cover here, which
I think is really important, is we're seeing a shift from
synchronous,
single threaded, single player development.
Right, think of a developer
sitting in VS code or sitting with
Quiro, whatever it is, and you're doing
a task.
Typically that task is one task at a
time, and that agent is taking over your IDE
so it's synchronous, and it's typically one developer,
it's single player.
But we're seeing a shift away into
multi-threaded, asynchronous
and multiplayer, right, so
maybe we've got a breakdown of 8 or 10 tasks,
we can farm those off to agents
simultaneously,
and the agents can do all of that work at the same
time.
And how does that change the dynamic
of what we do as software engineers
from a day to day
perspective.
And so we made this announcement at
GitHub uh Universe.
We call this Agent HQ because
we want GitHub to be the headquarters
of every agentic workflow.
Now this isn't actually a product. You're not gonna
go into GitHub and click on the agent HQ
tab,
because GitHub is the agent
HQ. And so, uh, what we
announced is, we have today, if you
go and give a task to coding agent,
you're using the co-pilot coding agent.
But what if you're a Clawed code fan? Anyone here
a fan of Clawed code? Alright, well what if
we, what if you wanna run your asynchronous workflows
with clawed code?
Well, just like we think models
are a commodity, you wanna use Gemini,
you wanna use clouded models, you wanna use
anthropic models,
we're gonna enable that.
We think agents are going to be commodity
as well. So if you wanna use co-pilot, you'll
get some advantages, but if you prefer Cloud,
we want to enable that, and so,
In the next couple of weeks, you will have the
ability to assign
issues asynchronously to Claude code,
or to Joules, or to
XAI,
uh, whatever agent you want to, in
the GitHub platform. So it'll still be where your
source code is,
it'll still be in your workflow, and
we will enable that for you.
And, and so, I'll show you some of the advantages you
get with co-pilot coding agents, but
if you want to use other agents, we were gonna
build the platform
that will support that.
But what about governance? Anyone
here have like security or compliance
teams that make sure that you do the
right thing?
OK, yeah, so as developers, we have to deal
with those folks.
And how do those folks actually
manage at scale? How can they
put into place policies
and procedures
and Uh, all of the vetting
that they need to do across different models and agents,
how can they do all of that? Well, we've got something
called the agent control plane,
which is the kind of the administrator's view. And
so the administrator can go into a single place
to approve the set of models that
your company is comfortable using.
They can define custom models, if you've got
your own models or you've got other model providers
that you want to use, you can put those in there.
Uh, you can define policies, you can define
custom agents,
that's all defined in a single place we
call the agent control plane. So this is kind of what the
administrators
and the compliance team would be
using to get comfortable
at scale with what we're building.
But for developers, you want a single
place where you can see all of the threads that
you've started, right?
If you're gonna really go into multi-threaded
development, you might have 8 or 10 or 12
things going at the same time. How do you see
where those are, how far they are, what
files have been changed,
and that's what we call mission control.
And uh I'll show you what Mission Control looks like.
We have that in the web, and we have that in Visual
Studio code as well.
Uh, it's early days for us, but we're trying to
build this place where you can start managing
and orchestrating all of this multi-threaded
work. All
right, so, uh, we'll put this slide up quickly.
Um, so this shows kind of all of the
actual features. So if you go into GitHub,
you will see things like autofix and code
quality,
and, uh, coding agent and agent mode.
So these are actually the, all of the features, and we've
tried to put them more or less in the phases
of the life cycle.
Uh, and, um,
we, we really like, we really
would hope that everyone would use all of these tools,
because we think there's some economies of scale that
you get across all of them.
But again, if you prefer another coding
agent, we're gonna make sure that we build in
the correct integration points for
that. Alright,
let's see.
Um, I'll, I'll mention a bit of metrics. I'm
not gonna spend too much time on this. So we, we
do have metrics,
uh, that will show how many, um,
how many users are using premium
models, what are the most popular models that
your developers are using?
Are they using coding agent or code review
agent?
Uh, so we've, we've got the beginnings
of metrics,
uh, and we're starting off on the left-hand
side with measuring usage and adoption. That's
really the focus
of our metrics.
And we're moving towards taking
the usage metrics and actually helping
you
change or helping you measure impacts.
Um, again, internally, we've started with
pull request lead time. How long does it take
from when you open a pull request to when it's merged,
and can we see any trends when
you're using co-pilot to create the pull
request or using co-pilot code review
to review the request? And the answer is yes,
we see those
trends, um, but we want to start getting those
trends and those metrics into our, the hands
of our users so that you can start measuring that
yourself in our dashboards and in our APIs.
All right, a couple more slides just to um
show some of the releases that we made, and then I'll
jump into some demos.
Um, so we think of agents as accelerators.
Um, so I've mentioned third-party agents, uh,
which is coming soon, in the next couple of weeks. I've mentioned
Mission Control.
Uh, we've got the co-pilot coding agent, which, uh,
which I'll show.
Uh, we've got custom agents,
anyone using our clouded skills, right,
so that's kind of similar clawed skills. It's
just a markdown file
that you can use to tell the agent
how you wanted to do a very particular task,
right? And so again, I'll demo that.
Uh, we've got co-pilot code review.
Uh, co-pilot code review before Universe,
so, uh, up until about a month ago, we
would take the diff
inside of PR. We would pass that to the agent, we'd
say, please do a review, and we had a system prompt
about how to do that review.
What we've added now is we've added what we call
agentic capabilities.
So now code review will run in an action.
Uh, so it'll actually start up a
runner, and so it actually has an environment where
it can execute tasks like linters
and code scanners.
Um, so I'll talk a little bit about that, but,
uh, co-pilot code review will now
give you the best of non-deterministic, asking
a model to do the review, and deterministic
tools like linters and our
code scanning tool.
Uh, and of course we've had agent mode for a while.
All right, so I wanted to put this slide up here because
um I like to use this as an example of
how we are trying to help our customers
actually think about development in new ways.
So I'll show you this demo.
Uh we have a, a website called Octocat
Supply. It's a React,
uh, no JS application, sort of e-commerce
application. And uh the demo that I've been doing for
ages with my customers is,
and I'll show, I'll show you some of that demo, not
the whole thing, but there's no cart page.
You can go to the product page and you can add products
in. And uh there's
just a placeholder, and I walk through
how we can use co-pilot coding agent
or agent mode,
or code completions to help build out
this cart page.
But one day I was thinking about, well, why am I only
building one cart page?
What if I don't know what the best
carp page design is?
What if I wanted to experiment with multiple carp
pages?
Well, before coding agents,
I'd probably get my team together and we'd discuss
several variations and then we'd pick one.
Before we even start, right? Because we don't
have time to do all three.
We don't have 3 teams that can do
the same work.
But because we now have agents, we're at a
place where we can say, all right,
I got co-pilot coding agent plan mode
to plan 3 different variations of
the cart page,
and create an issue for each variant, and
then assigned it to co-pilot, and co-pilot went
to work. On 3 different variations
at the same time, and about 25 minutes later,
I had 3 different versions of
the cart page. Now those screenshots there are
actually taken
as co-pilot coding agent was working, it
spins up the Playwright MCP server,
and it interacts with the website, and it actually takes a
screenshot and it puts it into the body of the PR.
And so you can actually see just in the body of the PR
the 3 different variations.
Of course, there's all the code there, they're on separate branches,
so I could check them out if I wanted to. If I
had a feature flag system, like
a launch Daly or something like that, I could actually
deploy all 3 and do load balancing and all of
that thing. But the point is
that this is a new muscle memory for developers.
Because we should start thinking about why should I
only do 1 variant.
Let me do 3 or 4 or 5,
because agents can take that offline
for me. We
also have uh.
Any,
anywhere you wanna access co-pilot coding
agent from, we wanna enable that. So we
announced
uh the co-pilot CLI. Anyone using co-pilot
CLI?
No one. All right, I'll have to show that to you.
You co-pilot CLI,
uh, so if you're a terminal warrior and you
don't like IDEs, you can use co-pilot
in your CLI.
Uh, we have plan mode and BS
code. Uh, we've got the GetUp MCP
registry. Anyone using MCP servers?
Anyone having a trouble securing
which MCP servers your teams can
use? OK, yeah, so we've got the MCP
registry.
We're on the, uh,
We're on the steering committee for
the MCP protocol, uh, so some of our
engineers work very closely with Anthropic to help
evolve that spec,
and uh we work, we think MCP
is a really important part of this future, so we've got
a lot of goodness around MCP
and MCP registries and whitelisting
servers and compliance and all of the good things
that enterprises want.
Uh, we also have co-pilot for Slack and Teams,
and for Azure boards and Linear if you're
using those tools for workout and tracking.
So this might be a little bit difficult to see, but I
actually took the screenshot from a thread
internally where
uh one of our Devrell advocates
had asked a question about configuration
for coding agent,
and he was like, well, the docs say
I can do this, but I'm struggling to do it. And
Tim, who's the uh product manager
for coding agent,
responded in the thread to say, oh, actually no, that's
a typo or a mistake in our docs
file. And then he said, at GitHub
co-pilot, go and fix this doc.
And that invoked co-pilot coding agent,
which grabbed the thread, so it had all the context,
created a pull request, and you can see
the green button about three quarters of the way down
that says go and view this PR. And so
all Tim had to do was go and view PR, do
the review,
and it was fixed. So, we're enabling
co-pilot coding agent from wherever you're working, be
that Slack or Teams or Mobile.
Uh, this morning, I had a workflow
that I've been using for some internal automation,
and I was getting spammed because that's on a
schedule that every 15 minutes it runs.
And I made an update
and didn't test it thoroughly, bad me.
Uh, but I was getting spammed because every 15
minutes, the workflow was failing and I was getting an
email. And so while I was walking
over here this morning, I opened up my mobile
and I copied the uh error from the
workflow run, and I put it
into coding agent to say, coding agent, here's
the error I'm getting, go and fix the workflow.
By the time I got here, I went to Starbucks
to have a cup of coffee, and as I was sipping
my coffee at Starbucks, I opened up the
pull request, saw that it had fixed it, merged
it in, and now I no longer have any spam
from a failing workflow, because coding agent fixed
it for me
while I was going over to the Mandalay
Bay. That's what we're trying to enable,
is anywhere you wanna work,
anywhere you wanna get results,
we want to enable that with coding agent.
Alright, so, but we also want to ship code that
lasts. It doesn't help if we create code
and you don't trust that code. So what we're doing is
we're integrating GitHub Advanced Security, which is
our app sec.
Tooling suite into coding agents. So
every time coding agent is working on a PR
it's going to run,
uh, tests. It's gonna make sure that the tests pass,
it's going to run uh the
review cycle, so it'll actually review the code
and get, get,
uh, get input from the review and then
fix that.
Uh, we're gonna run our codeQL scanning
tool, which is our SAST tool, our static analysis
scanning tool.
Uh, we will do secret protection.
And we will also invoke co-pilot
Autofix, which is the first agent we actually
had on our plat on our platform
that would help you to resolve
security vulnerabilities. So we're building all of
those security
features into every run of
co-pilot coding agent,
and also the code review agent.
So I'll show you what that looks like.
Uh, and I've mentioned most of these
before, so I'm just going to skip
this slide.
All right, let's switch over
to a quick demo.
And then I'll see if I've got time for a couple
of questions,
alright.
Let's see, all right.
So this is that Optoat supply
application. And if I
open this up, this is it running.
So if I click on products and add a product
to the cart, you can see there's just this little pop-up that
says I've added an item to the cart.
Uh, and so, let me show
you the repo where I
created a couple of issues or pull
requests.
Uh, so again, I use planning mode, which I'll
show in a couple of seconds to go and plan 3 different
variations of that cart page.
And then each one of those variations I assigned
to co-pilot.
So if we go and click on design C.
This is the pull request from that, and
you can see a nice summary here of everything that
was changed and updated. There's the screenshot
in the body of the PR
and I can also go all the way down here.
To the full session,
let me see if I can find the session.
Alright, so if I click view session, this is going to take
me to Mission Control.
Alright, so this is the panel where we'll see the full
log,
and this includes everything. At the bottom,
you can see the full summary, but I can see the entire
log, and so I can see exactly what the agent
was thinking as it was running. This first couple of
steps here are custom setup
steps,
because I have a particular version of Node JS
and so I want coding agent to use that.
And so we have a little workflow file that
you can specify to set up the environment
for coding agent,
and then,
We can see it
viewing files, right? So it's doing an LS
just to view all the files. When, when we
uh view a
an actual file. Let me see if I can find
a file, right? When we
Oh, OK, the path does not exist, alright, this is
an older repo.
Uh, but we can see every time it creates a file,
you can see the diff there
for the file it created. On the right-hand side,
um, you can see all of the files that were changed,
and you can add comments here. And then this box
at the bottom here, yeah, this session
has completed already,
but I could add another.
Instruction here for agent to go and do additional
work. If the session was actually running,
I could add an instruction here mid-stream,
all right, so if I see agent starts
going a little bit
into rabbit holes that I don't want it to
do, then I can do mid-steering
from this panel over here. And here
I get to see all of the threads
that I have queued off for coding agents. So that's mission
control. Uh, let's
go back to the repo here.
And I want to click on security.
Because I want to show
code quality, right? So code quality
is new and at the moment, we have sort of
two pivots for quality. We've got
um maintainability and
reliability.
And uh so what we'll do is we, we
do security scanning, but then this is actually
quality scanning. So anyone here using sonarCube.
Right, so this is kind of what SonoCube does,
except we're trying to do it a little bit better
than SonoCbee does.
All right, and so you can see the, the warnings below
here, and we can create, um, we can
create policies that will block this PR from
being merged if there are any errors
in the quality scans.
But if I open this up,
uh, let me open up one of these,
one of these alerts.
So let me see if I can click on that.
Not only do we show you the alert, we
actually invoke the autofix agent
to go and show the suggested fix.
All right, so
in this case it's fairly simple, but there may be
more complex scenarios where your
developers don't know how to fix that particular
issue. We use coding agent
to do that, so I can open a pull request here.
Uh, or I can just assign to co-pilot
that's coming soon, so I can get a co-pilot to go and fix
this. Um, but if I wanted to generate
a fix for this particular suggestion, I just
click that button and the co-pilot would go
and. Work out what
a fix would be for that
particular
uh warning. So that's our quality, that's
built in.
Uh, let me go over the pull requests here. I'm
gonna show another pull request here. We had a feature
to add terms of service download, all
right, so this was a human that implemented
this code,
uh, for this particular pull request.
And uh on the reviewers here, you can
see that I've assigned co-pilot as one of
the reviewers, right? So again, you can set a policy
here that every pull request gets a,
a review automatically
by code review.
Um, but if we scroll down here in
this, um,
in this pull request,
You'll see that we get a number of
warnings in line from GitHub Advanced
Security, so that's our security scanning tool.
Right, so it's gonna highlight code where it
finds a vulnerability, and then it's going to
give a link to that vulnerability,
and then the auto fix for how to fix that
vulnerability, right?
When I was a developer, the only thing I knew about
security was those were the people that blocked you from
going to Prague, right? So we don't want that.
We want developers to be able to fix and do
the right thing quickly.
And so we have the, the auto-fix
suggestion here.
And so I could just commit the suggestion if I'm
happy with that.
All right, so there's some security vulnerabilities
here, and I'll carry on going down. All right,
so we're very thorough.
All right. And then you'll see that we have the code quality
scan here. And this time instead of
showing security vulnerabilities, we're showing quality
issues again with the autofix
suggestions that you can just commit in.
And then if I keep going down, you'll see
this is the pull request summary.
So uh when
code review
agent does its work, it gives you a nice summary
of what it sees the changes are.
Um, so as a human reviewer, this is great
because it gives me a nice summary of what's going on. I
can make sure that I
am on the same page as code review agent or
vice versa.
There's even a summary per file here.
Uh, and then again there's autofi
suggestions for every time co-pilot
code review has a suggestion,
it's going to make a suggestion as well. So
you kind of get all of that
enabled either per repo or
at the org level for all your repos.
So we wanna enable security and quality
at scale.
Um, let me see if there's any
other demos I wanna do. Alright, so
I'll show you here, if I go back to
the code repo here.
Or to the code page on the repo,
you'll see this little panel here where I can either
chat with
co-pilot across this repo. So say I'm a
new developer and I'm trying to find out
how is this, uh,
how is this repo laid out, right? I might wanna
just open up a chat session, but then there's also
this agents panel, and if I open up that,
this is where I can enter in a task.
I want a new feature, I want the download,
the, the cart page or whatever it is.
And you'll also see that there are custom agents
here. If I click on this, you can see that
there's a number of custom agents. These are just markdown
files that live either at the repo or
at the, a special
GitHub private repo at the org level.
Uh, and you can see I've got TDD for example.
Um, so I can do test-driven development
here. Um, I've got a TDD planner to
plan out the scenarios. I've got TDD
red to go and write the failing test, and I've got TDD
green. To go and implement the code until
all the tests are passing, right, so those are the kinds of
things that
we can do. I've got a research bot
there so I can use that to do research,
etc. alright.
I wanted to show a planning agent here.
So let me grab this.
Alright, so I'm gonna again use the cart page
and I've got the text there for how I want the cart
page to look. I'm gonna drag an image
in here because this model actually
supports
uh vision.
Uh, so let me go through
docs, design.
Here's the cart page, that's what I want it to look like.
A designer might have given that to me, so I'm gonna just drag
that in.
I'm using Claude Opus 4.5, but
in the model picker you'll see all of the models that
we give you access to,
or that your admin has enabled, I should say.
But I'm using Claude Opus 4.5, which is a
really cool model.
And uh here under agent, you can see
there's different modes here. These are these custom
modes that I created.
And then out of the box, we have agent, plan, ask,
and edit. So I'll just put this into plan mode.
And I'm gonna get co-pilot to help
me plan out this feature.
You notice that I didn't give it, uh, instructions
about where I want the cart to be stored.
Do I want an API for that? Do I want to use local storage?
These are the kinds of things that I would expect a
planning agent to come back with, to say,
all right, I see what you're trying to do, but have you thought
about X and Y?
And uh it will do that. It'll take a couple of
seconds for that to run while that's going.
I wanted to actually hit this configure custom agents
button, and right at the bottom here, you
can actually see we have the plan mode there. If
I click on that,
this will give you the markdown file. So this is
the markdown file that ships with Visual Studio
code for plan mode. So plan mode is
just a custom agent that's defined
by a markdown file.
So you can go and look at that. If you do
something different for your planning, you can customize
that so you have a custom planning
mode
for co-pilot.
Uh, and so you see co-pilot is reading
a bunch of files and understanding what's going
on in the repository
before it starts asking me clarifying
questions.
And then you'll see these handoffs here where
the handoffs, it's gonna give me two
buttons, either start implementation
or open an editor, if I wanna actually
capture the plan in a markdown
file, it'll put two buttons at the bottom of that.
Those are called handoffs. Again, you can use that to make
your own custom modes. I did that for the,
TDD where after you've done TDD
planning, there's a button to say TDD red, and
after you run TDD red, there's a button that says TDD
green, so you can kind of start guiding your developers
along these agentic workflows.
Well, at least Opus is thorough. It's reading
every file in that repo.
All right.
Let's see what else. OK, I wanted to actually show
this panel here.
Uh, so if I click on this panel, you'll see that I have chat
history here. So these are all the chat sessions that
I had on the right-hand side. I've got all the
cloud sessions here, because I can actually
dispatch this to cloud using the little cloud
icon here, that'll go to coding agent
in the repo.
Down here I've got CLI, right, so if I
actually start a new agent session in the
terminal,
this will open the terminal with the really
cool animation.
For a co-pilot,
right, let's see that again, it's just so cool.
Uh, I'll do it one more time. So we're gonna open up
multiple CLI sessions.
Here it comes. Alright, there's co-pilot. All right.
So once it's up there, this is co-pilot
in the CLI. So for those of you that like
using clawed code, this should feel very
familiar to you. It's a terminal interface
onto co-pilot.
And then I could give it instructions to
go and do tasks, and if I have multiple
of those in flight at the same time,
we can track all of my CLI sessions here.
So this is kind of mission control view
inside of Visual Studio code,
kind of similar to what we had.
In Mission Control in the web.
All right, and so you see here, um
we've got the plan here. I'm not gonna read all of this, but
there might be some questions here. Further considerations.
Do you want a coupon system? What authentication?
Do you need to be authenticated to add items to the
cart? Right, so plan mode will help me
do that. I can either just hit start implementation
here, or I can start iterating, or if I hit
open an editor, I think this will create,
A markdown file for me, so if anyone's
doing spec-driven development, you could actually
save that markdown file into the repo,
so you kind of have a history of your planning
and the decisions that you've made.
Alright, so I am gonna pause there for
questions. I, I hope I've given you a kind of a, a
good high-level idea of what we're trying to build with
a couple of demos in there.
Uh, there's so much goodness in co-pilot, so
I encourage you to look at the change log. Uh, there
is a filter for co-pilot,
uh, cos there's a lot of stuff coming out. Uh,
but thank you for your time. I'll take a couple of
questions. Anyone, OK, someone's got a
question there. You're gonna have to shout, and then I'll repeat it.
horse. Uh,
OK, so I kind of caught the first half of that. There's
a microphone there,
yeah. Yeah,
where do you see the future of co-pilot
given that Kira is being so heavily pushed?
Well, I, um
Uh, that, so the.
We, we had coding agent, uh,
6 months ago.
Quiro's just come out with the autonomous
agent. Um,
there's a DevOps agent for in
Azure and AWS now.
Azure's had one on the, on the Microsoft
side, uh, again, since May of this year.
So, yeah, I, I think, um,
I think it's gonna be interesting to see how they
develop and where their strengths are. Again, we
think agents are gonna be a commodity.
So if
we don't have Quiro integration yet, but
I could see that on the roadmap at some point
that if you wanted to use Quiro as the agent for
doing whatever work, we would just integrate
that in. We really think that
the agents are commodities. What we're trying to build
is that end to end platform that
supports agentic autonomous work.
Again, we'll have to see how that exactly plays out,
but we're not particularly concerned
about that. Again, we, we see the agents as
commodity.
Alright, any other questions? Yes, there's one here.
What model
Do Advice
on instructions
for it. Because what the developers have noticed
is if you add a bunch of instructions to a repo,
Yep. All
right, so, the question is, what model
does Co-Pilott code review use? Uh,
that depends on your policies. So we will
try, um, Claude Sonnet 45.
If you have not allowed 45,
we will fall back to Sonnet 4.
we are working on model choice for
both code review and coding agents, because
at the moment, those are fixed pretty much
between uh Sonnet 45 and
GPD 5
are the models that we use for code review and coding
agent. But again, we're, we're, you
will see in the next couple of months that there will be a
model picker, so that you can pick which model you
want for those experiences.
Uh, the instructions files,
um, you can put them.
I, what I do for my instructions files is
in the GitHub co-pilot instructions
MD file.
Uh, I typically put review guidance at
the top of that file. So I have
general review guidance for the entire repo
here. And then you can also,
in the instructions
file here, you, this, uh, particular repo
has an API, a database, and a front-end.
And so I've split out.
Particular instructions for those three portions
of that code base and so
API here you can see the apply to has
a glob
where I'm saying if there are changes in
this set of folders,
then use these instructions and again
I've got specific review instructions
for the API at
the top there but again. I think this is something
that it doesn't matter what agent you're using.
This is a challenge is figuring out
how much or how little your instructions
need to be in order to get good results.
If you give it too much,
that can confuse the model. If you give it too little,
it does its own thing. So I think
this is just going to be something that's a challenge
no matter what agent or model you're using.
But we're hoping that we at least are giving you some of the
mechanisms that you need to start separating
out instructions for different portions
of your repo to get better.
Uh, instructions there. The other thing
which you'll see in the plan mode.
If I can find that is.
Something called, uh,
did I close it?
Called run sub agent.
So configure custom agents, let's go to plan.
Uh, down here, you can see
that we actually do, uh, what's
called a sub-agent,
right, where sometimes you want the agent to do some
research, but you don't wanna clutter the entire
conversation with all of that research. You want it to go and do its
research, iterate, and then just come back with the final
result. That's what the sub-agent does, it kind of
starts a new thread,
keeps all the context in that thread,
and just comes back with the final result.
So I think over time you'll see things like
code review.
Um, become better as we enable
sub-agents, because you're not gonna have the context
being blown out by the first couple of lines
of code.
Uh, we'll get better at managing that context
through things like the sub-agent tool.
Great question.
Alright, I think I've got time for maybe 1
or 2 more. Yep, there's 1 over there.
There's a microphone just behind you.
Um, yeah, is there a way to get it to work
across multiple repos,
not just one repo at a time? Yeah,
I wish you hadn't asked that question. That's a great
question. Uh,
again, like this is something I keep bugging our, our
team about. Um,
the GitHub GitHub repo is a mono repo,
so our engineering team is used to working on a giant
mono repo.
I keep telling them that there are other companies that work
differently,
um, but that's something that again I think will,
will certainly come
as we iterate mission control. I think that will be
the surface where you'll see it. So you'll see something
like what Quiro does where you can
put in 5 or 10 repos and have
it do work across those.
Um, so we'll, we'll, we'll get there. We're trying to figure
out what exactly the right interface
and user experience is for that.
Great question. Thanks for making
it hard.
Alright,
one more question, yes,
there you go, there's a microphone,
thank you E-Rod.
So I find myself enjoying the
uh inline suggestions. I kind of get
to review and scrutinize as
I go. How do you as a developer choose
between. Doing prompt engineering
versus
taking those in lines.
That is a great question. All right. So I've, I've
found, uh, the more, the more I meet
with customers over this, uh,
the more I realized this is less about the models and
the technology and more about the change management,
uh, and the training and the enablement, uh,
just like any tool or technology, you can't
just give it to a developer and get good results.
You need to actually spend time investing in
Uh, new muscle memory, new ways of thinking,
um, I, I think we, we
wanna enable whatever experience the
developer wants. There's some developers that really want
that. I wanna be in a code file
and I wanna be writing code and I wanna get the suggestions
just for that code.
There are other developers that are like, I don't really care.
I'm gonna describe what I want and I want co-pilot
to give me results.
Um, we're trying to enable
whichever design or the
coding experience you prefer,
um. I think we're, we're
probably investing more in the autonomous
agent side of things because we just
see that scaling a lot more,
um, because of the shift from synchronous
single player, which is the code completion
experience, into that
I've got a set of tasks and I want co-pilot
to work on all of them at the same time. So I think
we're leaning a little bit more to that,
but we're not gonna leave the uh the code completion
experience behind.
Again, we think that's
more or less preference. I use a bit of
both. I'm probably like 90% agent mode
and coding agent and about 10%
code completion.
Again, that's gonna vary depending on your style.
Yep, good question.
Alright, well, I'll, I'll stick around for another
minute or two, but thank you very much. Enjoy
the rest of the conference and safe travels. Alright,
thank you.